President Biden giving a fiery address
to the nation saying the real threat to
democracy comes from Mega Republicans
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic Maggie
Republicans do not respect the
Constitution they're Maggie Republicans
extreme Maggie Republicans Maggie
Republic is an extreme mag ideology
Maggie Republicans Maggie Republicans
Maga forces are determined to take this
country backwards the Maggie Republicans
believe that for them to succeed
everyone else has to fail Maggie
Republicans looking Americans see
Carnage and darkness and despair
the White House insist the address was
not political and critics are blasting
the president over the tone calling it
dark and divisive and it wasn't just the
words some noting the blood red backdrop
and the Optics of having two marines
flanking the president Republicans have
been tearing into Biden's speech
the strange and wildly inappropriate
setting the unusual weird red lighting
most worrisome having Marines standing
behind him in which he's engaging in
political attacks on 74 million
Americans an assault on the soul of
America the political speech it was a
divisive speech and that's not
presidential very cynical attempt
um to fill our hands was stupid
he always has a way with words and some
of the media though are praising Biden's
address
that speech was exactly why President
Biden ran for president in the first
place they finally got it right you know
literally stay single-minded right now
Biden laid out the Democratic platform
into the midterms and into 2024. it's an
important speech remember Lincoln gave a
speech in 1860 and what did we what
happens we have the Civil War we have
folks who reject the basic premise what
was more pro-usa than this speech and I
think this is exactly what his what
democratic voters wanted to hear
so Biden has been trying to clarify the
controversy over his remarks
Mr President do you consider all Trump
supporters to be a threat to the country
yeah everyone come on
consists upon changing the way in which
the rules you
that is a threat to democracy
so Greg I want to come to you first
about this obviously the president was
trying to thread the needle here to make
sure that we were differentiating
between Mega Republicans and the bulk of
the Republicans
obviously really well he said it like 50
times no he didn't yeah we did they did
because you couldn't he pretend he wait
no yes that's not proving your point
though what he did was he took uh took
an amorphous group of people in which he
cannot name decides that it's a huge
threat and then changes his mind and
says it's a small threat and then he
says but it's still a threat so come
join me and if you don't join me you're
a Nazi
the first thing you've got to understand
about this is you've got to have fun
with this this is hilarious you can't be
like the media and you can't be like the
Democrats when every time Donald Trump
spoke or was at a rally or the
inauguration their hair was on fire
right they and then and Trump supporters
would be attacked this is what the media
wants you to do right now this is what
Joe Biden wants you to do right now he
wants they're trying to goad you into an
emotional state for violence that's what
they actually want this was the funniest
one of the funniest this little ticket
was put on by South Park Joe tried I
mean he's Darth Vader and Depends they
tried to project some kind of Darkness
on the Republican party but it actually
projected backwards right it looks like
a dystopian movie trailer in which the
dead president is being played by a
hologram the whole vibe was hilariously
creepy uh it was it it you can't get mad
at this but you have to compare it to
what's going on around in the world
China and Russia are launching joint war
games and Joe is launching a war on us
right and if that if mag Republicans are
the biggest threat to our country maybe
we shouldn't be sending 50 billion 70
billion dollars to Ukraine to fight
Russia maybe you should be carpet
bombing churches and and country clubs
and golf courses and fraternities
because that's probably where the Magna
Republicans are I mean imagine if this
speech was about if you took Maga out of
it and you put China or you put Russia
it would have been an amazing foreign
policy wartime speech he would have
galvanized people to fight you know the
greatest enemy and then you realize no
wait he's talking about Americans
Americans that he claims he can mind
read but he cannot identify he cannot
decide if it's large or small but you
better join him or you're a threat to
democracy we're all Americans he says
except you and you and you and you it's
at you've got to laugh at this probably
one of the funniest presidential moments
in history
sorry I didn't answer your question
you know a president declaring war on
his own people and I went back to Italy
and I looked at Old speeches of
President Trump's and his fourth of July
speech in 2020 was all about uh
defeating the radical Left Right calling
out a group of people who an amorphous
group I would say because I get called a
radicalist all the time BLM writers
that's not that is not amorphous you can
see that but you can see people who are
trying to thwart democracy he named very
specific things that they're doing but
anyway Kaylee to that point how is this
a departure from divisiveness that we've
never seen before it's a huge departure
look my former boss was a counter
puncher there's no doubt about that you
look at what he said you attack him he
attacks you if you go back and look at
his attacks almost all of them 99.9
maybe 100 percent were against a person
who has attacked him were against a
politician they were not against a group
of people the White House did not set
out on a campaign to attack half the
country I did not stand at the podium
and say you just don't bite and build
back America people we hate you I didn't
do that Korean Jean-Pierre stands at the
podium nearly daily and talks about the
Maga Republicans this is a sustained
campaign from the chief of staff press
secretary president against half the
country you don't believe me he said
that the the Republican party is
dominated and driven by Donald Trump and
the Maga Republicans what does dominated
mean it means taking over it means more
than half and then today he comes out
tries to clean and clean it up I don't
consider any Trump supporters a threat
to the country really well you said that
last night Mr split personality because
I watched it by the way in a room full
of Mega Republicans who all heard very
clearly what you thought of us in the
rest of the country okay so I do have a
memory long enough for When Donald Trump
did attack full groups like calling for
a shutdown of the Muslim travel ban for
instance his original comments about
Mexican
no that was yeah no there were
non-muslim majority countries in there
it was about a terror threat
all right guys anyway JoJo would love to
get your thoughts on this video
you know I would like to agree with Greg
and say that
um this was a joke but I can't make a
joke out of this this is a man who's
dividing his nation and galvanizing
people on the left to hate people on the
right it was divisive it was ominous
there was a blood red background he
stood in darkness claiming that he
stands for light with military behind
him
he demonized half of Americans and I
don't care what he says today he said
yesterday Donald Trump and the mega
Republicans that 74 million of Americans
that he's supposed to be representing
threaten their very way of life baloney
you don't have a right to say that Mr
President you took a note to represent
all of us and just because people have a
different opinion about right to life
abortion Law and Order a secure border
you can't just say you're disgusting
your semi-fascists and Ergo I'm gonna
you don't you don't represent what's
great about America you compare us to
the likes of Hitler and Mussolini and
then you try to Gin up the Americans to
say that we are less than human and
deserving of the same result ultimately
that they are what makes Joe Biden think
he speaks for the soul of America what
makes him think in the middle of this
political diet tribe that that he speaks
for the rule of law or the Constitution
alone Hillary Clinton said Donald Trump
was an illegitimate president put in by
the Russians Stacey Abrams said that
that election was stolen from her alone
now yeah okay but but but what we've got
is look politics is one thing I get it I
ran for office five times people call me
names I probably called them names so it
goes but you don't demonize hard-working
Americans who simply want to survive and
want to hear about inflation gas prices
and crime they don't want to hear about
this nonsense if he's drawing a line
saying we're good and you are bad
quick you Joey are we doomed yeah uh
certainly at this table we are but no
we're not doomed uh we need to see this
with Clear Eyes I'm not going to speak
to the pundits right now I'm going to
speak to regular Americans I'll with all
due respect to those of us at the table
folks that go to work every day and have
other things to care about then whether
or not this was a political speech
because that was the debate on TV today
thank you Republican politicians for
making the talking point today whether
or not that was a political speech why
didn't you talk about what he said he
said either you support the green New
Deal or you're racist how do you support
sexualizing kids in school with uh trans
reading hour or you're a bigot how do
you support what the Democrats did do in
2020 legally which was to venture into
the gray area of how to collect votes or
your anti-democratic so if you support
the Georgia uh the the Georgia bill that
made elections much more standardized
and got a lot more people to come out if
either you support that or you're or you
actually know what democracy is and then
he said in Joe Biden's best words either
you vote for Joe Biden or you ain't a
patriot that's what he said that's what
he said to every single American out
there and let me tell you something yeah
president Trump did look at the media a
class of Americans and say you know that
you're the enemy of the people Joe Biden
looked into the camera and told a class
of Americans that the people are the
enemy of the people the people who turn
wrenches who go to work every day the
people whose callers will never be white
because of the grease that gets on them
that's who the Maga Republicans are you
don't get to say that bill Crystal Adam
kinzinger and their dozens of followers
or mainstream Republicans to excuse
yourself out of demonizing half the
country that's not how this works so
whoever the Frank Lunt says style
pollster that told the Democrats that uh
this Ultra Maga light 1000s is the way
to go keep it up please keep it up
because you're going to see in November
how Americans feel about it
see well and I think the table today was
a good microcosm of the different
perspectives that people were having as
far as the Marines go in the background
that's their job their ceremonial guard
Marines guard the president even when
he's acting like a jack
um backside so all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else